ladies and gentleman je viens vous
parler aujourd'hui du nouveau smartphone
pliable de samsung c'est le samsung
galaxy z fold de cela tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le successeur du samsung galaxy
folle que je vous ai déjà présenté
l'année dernière puisque je sais pas si
vous le savez mais samsung a également
sorti en début d'année un nouveau
smartphone pliable qui s'appelle le
samsung galaxy z flip la gamme pliable a
trouvé son nom elle s'appelle la gamme z
galaxy z
mais avant toute chose et si vous l'avez
pas déjà fait vous invite à venir vous
abonner en cliquant sur petit bouton
rouge que vous avez juste ici pour tout
savoir sur l'actuel groupe harles de
smartphones pliable non plaisir je vous
parle bien évidemment de mon ordinateur
et je vous parle surtout de vous de
votre vie numérique des bons usages donc
cliquer sur le petit bouton rouge juste
ici activer la cloche comme ça vous
sauvera tous dès qu'une prochaine vidéo
arrivera je sais pas si vous étiez
intéressé à la première version du
smartphone pliable de samsung il était
très intéressant moi j'avais beaucoup
aimé mais vraiment beaucoup aimé mais il
y avait deux trois petits trucs que je
n'ai pas trop notamment l'écran vous
aviez à l'avant qui était quand même pas
très grand vu la surface disponible
du coup on se retrouve avec des énormes
grosses bandes noires en haut c'était
plus que des bornes c'était des blocs
donc là je peux l'utiliser je dirais sur
l'android classique je pousse la
luminosité à fond chaque capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est
extrêmement ralenties ça c'est cool et à
l'intérieur vous aviez un module photo
qui dans une espèce d'énorme encoches
sur le côté et il y avait un côté un peu
disgracieux petite encoche là je suis
moyennement fans mais bon bah c'est le
début ça me saoule a vraiment
retravailler sa copie pour nous proposer
un grand écran extérieur cette fois
aussi qui est vraiment grand et ça c'est
super et à l'intérieur on à la
disparition de cette espèce de grosse
encoches pas très joli et on se retrouve
avec le petit point sont vous le dis
tout de suite je le pense je suis
persuadé que sur la v3 vers et
potentiellement révélé prochaine
on m'aurait plu tout petit troupeau la
caméra on devrait avoir une caméra
intégrée sous l'écran et pourquoi pas
plusieurs caméras intégrées sous l'écran
plus que ce sont les techno qui
commencent à arriver fin 2020 mais sans
ne reparlera de [ __ ] et il ya un autre
point qu'il vachement intéressant est
que vient apporter ce samsung galaxy z
fold 2 c'est une charnière de meilleure
qualité
je m'étais pas rendu compte alors ce
qu'on avait le galaxy fold première
version romain je le trouve intéressant
il s'ouvrit comme un livre on pouvait
l'ouvrir naviguer bref c'était vraiment
intéressant et on avait déjà vu une
différence avec le galaxy et flip en
début d'année pouviez positionner la
charnière comme vous
le seul
des bulgares
dgo
m
ça vous permettait de poser sur une
table et de pouvoir l'utiliser pour
prendre des photos pour regarder des
films sur un plus petit écran c'est
vraiment autre chose mais on pouvait
faire et là ça me souviens vraiment
retravailler sa charnière de son grand
pliable en utilisant la charnière de son
petit plus agressive ou le physique
[Musique]
l'idée c'est que ça permet d'apporter de
nouveaux usages avec ce samsung galaxy
cette folle de 2 notamment pour le
visionnage de films notamment pour la
photo notamment pour le travail à pas
mal de possibilités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier truc qui m'a vraiment
intéressé lors de la présente c'est déjà
ce grand écran extérieur et croyez-moi
ça vient vraiment apporter quelque chose
parce qu'on a un smartphone un peu plus
standards du moment où j'ai grandi mais
quand je dis ça mais on est sur un
smartphone un peu long avec un grand
écran bon ok ça fonctionne là y'a pas de
soucis mais au moins on a des usages
c'est à dire que lorsque vous voulez pas
forcément l'ouvrir vous êtes dans les
transports en commun vous n'allez pas en
dehors du cac petit peu trop et bien
pouvait venir naviguer vous pouvez venir
envoyer des sms pour venir faire plein
de choses très facilement beaucoup plus
facilement vous ne pouviez pas avec la
version précédente ça c'est vraiment un
très très gros bénéfices au lieu d'abord
un écran de 4,7 pouces à l'avant comme
on avait ce modèle de l'année dernière
on se trouve avec un écran de 6,2 pouces
on a 60 % de plus d'affichage on pourra
faire plus de choses et en terme
d'expérience sait vraiment mais vraiment
beaucoup plus confortable la résolution
c'est du full hd plus ici on a un écran
super amoled avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 60 hertz est
protégée avec le dernier verre de
corning le corning gorilla glass est
même si c'est pas son nom exact
néanmoins c'est bien ces résistants ces
pratiques et c'est très rassurant
c'est un smartphone qui va être un poil
plus large mais qui en prise en main se
tiendra on est sur des grosses grosses
bêtes ça reste quand même relativement
épais j'imagine qu'à l'avenir et les
techno évolué entre et bien on se
retrouvera avec des smartphones un peu
moins épais pour l'instant on n'y est
pas c'est un smartphone qui pèse quand
même 2 179 g mais qui malgré tout
trouvera facilement sa place dans un sac
à main suffisamment grand dans une
grande poche
alors il se retrouve avec deux couleurs
le moustique blacks avec un verre plutôt
réfléchissant et on a le mystique bronze
comme l'a connue notamment sur le
samsung galaxy note 20 et qui lui par
contre est complètement matt est très
sympa alors après vous avez un
smartphone comme ça il faut vraiment
dire le protéger avec une coque donc bon
la couronne aux smartphones c'est très
joli mais elle risque de disparaître
derrière une jolie coque à l'intérieur
lorsque vous ouvrez le galaxy z fold 2
vous avez un écran de 7,6 pouces contre
5,3 pouces avant ça va pas part aux
hyper flagrant lorsque je les prie en
main mais lorsque je les compare avec
l'autre modèle effectivement on voit
légèrement la différence est notamment
au niveau des morts ici c'est un écran
dainik amoled avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 120 hertz tout ça
comptera plus de fluidité et notamment
pour la partie gaming parce que oui ici
vous pouvez venir jouer vous avez un
smartphone qui est réparé forum ça je
vois pas dans quelques instants la
différence pour avec le modèle de
l'année dernière également c'est que
c'est facile on a
r qui est ultra fins comme sur le galaxy
z flip un verre ultra fins qui peut se
plier
soyez rassurés mais le toucher est
différent par rapport au galaxy fold
l'année dernière donc il ya un vrai
bénéfice là dessus aussi
et on a une résolution en quad hd +
alors quad hd + oui mais vous n'aurez
pas un taux de rafraîchissement de sang
derrière ce en quoi vous serez en full
hd plus c'est la même chose que sur les
galaxies d'alevins et samsung galaxy s
alors qu'on nous propose ici avec un
grand écran comme ça c'est effectivement
confort de visionnage c'est des
expériences de gaming maximiser mais
c'est également le multitâche mois le
multitâche je ne suis pas persuadé qu'on
en fasse même si l'écran est très grand
on peut le faire ça peut être pratique
est ce que vous faites vous d'ailleurs
du multitâche avec votre smartphone je
sais pas si vous avez un très grand
smartphone galaxy note galaxie folle
pourquoi pas est ce que vous faites du
multitâche wind ont marqué deux mois en
bas en commentaire par contre l' usage
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est que
grâce à cette nouvelle charia là vous
pouvez venir mettre comme ça 90 degrés
ça vous permet d'avoir de nouveaux
usages vous dit en termes de photos en
termes de productivité en termes de
visionnage de films et de séries et je
trouve ça vraiment pratique il ya un
vrai bénéfice exceptionnel qui a été
complètement repensé au travail et
parlons justement de la performance ça
sympa qui est extrêmement intéressant
sur les modèles européens vous avez un
soc exynos exynos 990 notamment ceux
d'agnès samsung galaxy note 20 mai sur
les versions us vous avez le dernier soc
de qualcomm c'est le stand dragon 165
ici vous avez un soc de qualcomm mais ce
n'est pas le 865 6 865 plus qui va être
le plus puissant donc ici vous allez
avoir une machine qui va être
extrêmement performante extrêmement
puissante tous accouplé à 12 giga de ram
et à 256 go de stockage en urss trois
points donc ça nous confère aux
smartphones extrêmement puissant
extrêmement performant avec une
expérience de gaming avec un très grand
écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 120 m autant vous dire que là
franchement vous êtes partis pour un bon
petit moment mais derrière ça vous avez
une grosse batterie de 4500 milliards
eur seul modèle derrière vous avez une
batterie de 4000 380 millions pour
l'heure on a un petit bénéfice de la
recharge rapide 25 watts vous pouvez
avoir la recharge sans fil 15 watts
également de l'argent versé pour venir
charger vos galaxie bloodlines et
compagnie tout ce que vous vous donc au
terme de puissance en terme de
performances en termes d'autonomie on a
quelque chose qui est extrêmement
cohérent tout ça tourne sous la dernière
version de one way basé sur l'android
disent autant dire que l'expérience est
vraiment très très bonne vous pouvez
insérer
seule carte sim ici pas de double sim et
bien évidemment c'est un smartphone qui
n'a absolument aucune certification
parce que ce typologie de produits avec
une charnière aujourd'hui ça ne certifie
pas côté photo à l'arrière vous avez un
triptyque de 12 mégapixels tous en or
par un peu plus tard lors du test donc
on verra réellement ce qu'on est capable
de faire en termes de photos avec et
vous avez deux caméras de salfit 10
mégapixels une lorsque votre smartphone
va être complètement fermée sur
l'extérieur vous avez une caméra de 10
mégapixels et lorsque vous l'ouvrez à
l'intérieur dans le petit point sont
vous avez également une caméra de 10
mégapixels
ici vous pouvez filmer jusqu en 4k à 60
images par seconde
pas du mica comme souvent retrouvé sur
la gamme s et sur la gamme note ici on
va plutôt se concentrer sur le grand
écran et la modularité du produit plutôt
qu'aller faire de la vidéo 8 cas ça
aurait pu avoir un sens que ça me saoule
montre les muscles est sûre en intégrant
cette techno après est-ce qu'on va film
en uc a personnellement je ne suis pas
du tout persuadé il n'y a pas réellement
tout de suite d' usage grand public à
venir film en 8k après on aurait pu dire
qu'on a un produit qui est vraiment
destiné aux technophiles
il pourrait y avoir un sens avant de la
ligue 1 derrière bon voilà je sais pas
ce que peut vous intéresser des
redéploiements en bas en commentaires
que vous pourriez vous filmez votre
smartphone en 8k ou alors est-ce que
pour vous aujourd'hui ça reste plus
gadget est anecdotique marqué le mans
bat on commente pour les gamer on peut
avoir le game face xbox il a bien
évidemment des haut parleurs stéréo pour
l'expérience multimédia on a vraiment
quelque chose qui est top pour le
multimédia on est bon pour la
productivité au début en pour le gaming
est bien évidemment très très bon pour
la photo on en reparlera lors du test
parce qu'il faut l'essayer mais
connaissant le travail de samsung au
niveau des capteurs au niveau de
l'intégration je ne doute pas qu'on ait
vraiment résultats qui sont vraiment
très très très bon on en parlera bien
évidemment dans quelques temps dont vous
invite à venir vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas
est ce un smartphone qui est disponible
dès maintenant en pré-réservation si
vous intéresse je vous ai mis les liens
en bas dans la description et qui sera
dispo à partir du 18 septembre prochain
enfin prochain ça dépend qui le moment
de regarder cette vidéo moment où je
tourne c'est un peu avant si vous la
regardez après il est déjà disponible
vous êtes après un peu l'histoire est au
tarif de 2020 euros on reste sur un
produit qui est quand même un peu niche
et qui est quand même un peu cher a
priori samsung pourrait sortir un peu
plus tard probablement l'année prochaine
des smartphones pliable ou enchère plus
abordable pour le grand public ça peut
sens de l'histoire et on commence
toujours par le trio de gamme et après
on démocratiser les produits donc si
vous êtes technophiles et vous avez un
gros budget avec dans votre smartphone à
ce que voulaient les dernières
innovations et bien ce smartphone est
vraiment cool et très intéressant mais
on confirme à tout ça bien évidemment
du test ultérieurement et si vous vous
dites j'aimerais bien le pliable mai
2000 euros ou 1500 euros pour le galaxy
z fleet aujourd'hui c'est pas possible
pour moi eh bien il se peut qu'en 2021
il ya des modèles plus abordables qui
arrivait bien évidemment tout ça on en
reparlera ultérieurement et à noter
qu'avec ce tarif vous bénéficiez de
l'assurance samsung pierre plus pendant
un an
on a donc un smartphone qui évolue par
rapport à la première mouture du samsung
galaxy fog une charnière qui s'est
amélioré en s'appuyant sur celle du
samsung galaxy z flip une très très
belle proposition c'est vraiment un
super joli produit plus destinée je vous
lise aux technophiles parce que
forcément tout de suite un petit peu
cher franchement 2020 euros mais un très
joli produit surtout très très belle
innovation de la part de samsung a vous
de me dire vous maintenant ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous trouvez ce samsung galaxy z folle 2
est ce qu'il pourrait vous tentez est ce
que vous le préférez au galaxy z flip
entre les deux vers lequel votre coeur
balance mark et moi ça bien évidemment
bon commentaire quant à nous je trouve
extrêmement rapidement parce qu'à plein
de choses qui arrivent
je vous emmène avec moi en voyage très
rapidement masqué bien évidemment gestes
barrières gagne évidemment sur ce prenez
soin de vous et je vous dis à très vite
où nous avons beaucoup d'amour bisous
bisous territoriales
[Musique]